spotlight is on a busy road in the
southwest valley tonight after a fatal
crash happened earlier this week
wednesday at furnace gulch in fort
apache
south of blue diamond now the suspect
was identified
as rising high school basketball star
zion collins who appeared in court
yesterday
on a handful of charges police on scene
say he was traveling
at excessive speeds and possibly under
the influence
joe moeller spoke to people in that area
who say that section of fort apache
needs to be addressed
he lives right where the crash happened
with more now joe
brian well this memorial is growing
today and tonight we just saw
some more it looked like family members
come here and drop off some flowers
right where this crash happened here at
furnish gulch and ford apache
you can see that there's a fence up
where this crash happened and just to
the left of your screen is
ford apache we talked to neighbors who
expressed concerned
concerns about the speed that people
travel down this road
something like this it kind of shakes
you up it's devastating
it's devastating something like this
could have been
it never should have happened a
temporary fence
is up and a memorial is growing where 52
year old eric echeverria was killed in a
crash wednesday just down the road from
his home
it's a pretty graphic reminder of what's
happened and what could have been
prevented
police say the suspect 19 year old zion
collins was allegedly driving around 88
miles per hour in a 35 mile per hour
zone
police also say there was a green leafy
substance found in the car
neighbors here say the speeding on fort
apache is a problem
as soon as they opened this road up they
took the stop signs out
and it's just a free for all eric
lamunian says when a stop sign at gomer
in fort apache was taken out the
speeding picked up
this has been very difficult lately
since they opened the street
carlos campos lives in the home where it
happened and called 9-1-1
a lot of motorcycles drive through here
and
very high to speed and also cars they
don't respect the
speed limits as a family grieves the
loss of a loved one neighbors here say
more can be done law enforcement
presence
and a at least a signal there a signal
or
you know put back the stop signs
now back out here live the family who
also lives in this neighborhood is
planning a vigil here at this
intersection this sunday
at 6 pm reporting live in the southwest
valley joe mohler 8 news now